[Music]
on this Sunday night the growing impact
of kovat 19 churches shut down world
landmarks closed as more nations report
the spread of the disease a breakthrough
in northern BC after weeks of nationwide
protests word of a proposed arrangement
in a major pipeline dispute it is a
milestone in the history of Canada what
we know about the proposal and honoring
the legacies of the victims of flight
752 I wanted to to stay in academia to
keep mojgan's name alive the push to
finish the work of Canadian researchers
who were killed
normal national with Bob and Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us
we begin with unprecedented new steps to
fight the spread of copán 19 for the
first time in its history
South Korea's Catholic Church canceled
Sunday Mass as that country grapples
with the worst outbreak outside of China
at least 65 countries worldwide have now
detected the virus in Italy where entire
towns are on lockdown
more than 30 people have died it's one
of many countries struggling to contain
the virus
Ross Flores has tonight's top story in
South Korea the blame game is under way
some officials want leaders of a church
to be investigated on murder charges
over the coronavirus the reason they say
some members visited the epicenter of
the outbreak the Chinese city of Wuhan
in January then church leaders allegedly
interfered with government efforts to
fight the outbreak this South Korean
Health Director says two patients who've
been placed under self quarantine have
died leading him to question how medical
resources were allocated that challenged
applying medical might properly is a
growing priority and not only in Asia of
cases in Britain rising into the dozens
the government is stepping up its
response what they're doing is testing
literally thousands of cases we've I
think done about 10,000 so far and as
you know we found about 35 people in
this country have or have had the
illness and clearly there may be more in
Italy tourism is running dry as that
country grapples with a major outbreak
another tourism landmark the Louvre
museum in Paris closed Sunday staffers
reportedly refused to work over fears of
contamination the Paris half marathon
was also postponed but hundreds of
athletes ran anyway some suggesting new
rules limiting large gatherings infringe
on their freedom of movement more
conspicuous are boasts of confidence
like this one from Iran's Islamic
Revolutionary Guard Tara did nominate
mokoro Naru we will defeat coronavirus
don't worry
this garret official despite Duran's
death toll climbing well into the dozens
the highest number outside China some
neighbors have closed their borders with
Iran more signs of international inertia
Ross Lord Global News Jason breaking
news here in Canada public health
officials say four nuke ovid 19 cases
have been confirmed in Ontario that
brings the total number in Canada to 24
south-of-the-border
an outbreak is growing in Washington
State Jennifer Johnson has that angle
officials in King County Washington now
reporting two more cases of kovat 19
bringing the number of cases to six in
the same County that saw the first u.s.
death related to the virus officials
still don't know how the man who died
was infected we have CDC on the ground
immediately to assist and support and
they're working to identify it but
researchers say the virus in Washington
may have been spreading for weeks and up
to 1500 residents could be infected
forcing the governor to declare a state
of emergency at this Seattle area
nursing home two people have tested
positive for kovat 19 and over 50 others
are showing symptoms we're in the
process of investigating this situation
as an outbreak
the virus is spreading to America's East
Coast Rhode Island's governor is
reporting it's apparent first case of
COBIT 19 be careful and be vigilant but
don't panic the US Surgeon General is
urging Americans to stop buying facemask
carrying a shortage for health care
professionals president Donald Trump now
says travelers going to high-risk
countries will be screened before and
after returning to America still he's
facing backlash after calling Democrats
criticism of his response to the crisis
a hoax this is not a democratic coast
this is incompetence on the part of the
president United States at the expense
of the country in the world many experts
are questioning why there still are so
few test kits for the virus in the u.s.
the Trump administration has given the
Food and Drug Administration emergency
authorization to create more we now have
the capability in out in the field to
test 75,000 people and within the next
week or two we'll have a radical
expansion health officials sending out
mixed messages some urging the public
not to panic because the risk of
getting the viruses low while others
promising this first death is only the
tip of the iceberg President Trump will
meet with major pharmaceutical companies
Monday about the development of a
possible vaccine but that could take
some time
he'll also meet with doctors at the
Centers for Disease Control later this
week Jennifer Johnson Global News
Washington a breakthrough today in those
tense talks in BC to settle that
pipeline protest and end rail blockades
across Canada there's word a proposed
arrangement on land rights in title has
been reached between with so attend
hereditary chiefs and the federal
government our Sarah McDonald is in
northern BC with details of the proposal
history in the making in northern BC
this is where it starts duty to consult
as well as the rights in title with a
potentially precedent setting proposed
agreement reached between indigenous
leaders and government officials process
to recognize rights in title for the
future we've done that in three days and
three nights the conclusion of
exhaustive intensive and at times
difficult dialogue on rights and title
and reconciliation and exactly what that
looks like going forward we are
definitely looking at sitting down with
the RCMP again because it's not over the
eyes of the nation fixated on talks only
a select few could actually witness all
unfolding behind closed doors as unrest
among supporters of the with so it's a
nation Chiefs opposed to a natural gas
pipeline ripples cross country it is
about making sure that this never
happens again that the rights holders
will always be at the table and that is
the way through for for Canada but that
proposed agreement which still needs the
approval of the what so it in people is
not retroactive and this multi-billion
dollar project backed by band councils
remains fully permanent with work on
hiatus for the duration of discussions
resuming Monday the future of already
tenuous and complicated relationships
remains clouded in uncertainty the one
thing is undisputed
all this and this about far more than
just a pipeline in a province sitting on
territory that's mostly in ceded and the
premier of BC and the Prime Minister
both said to have been intimately
involved in the creation of that draft
agreements both of them said to be ready
and willing to sign it so long as the
with soda and people are first Robin sir
MacDonald reporting from northern BC
it's not yet clear if the progress made
in British Columbia this weekend will
satisfy thousands of protesters who have
spent the last few weeks setting up
blockades and shutting down rail lines
across the country many demonstrations
have gone far beyond original concerns
over that natural gas pipeline david
aiken explains these protesters gathered
outside one of the world's biggest
mining industry conferences which opened
sunday in downtown toronto to let the
world know they have a beef with the
global mining industry we know that if
we allow their business as usual to
continue it will literally lead to an
unlivable planet they were also standing
in solidarity with the Witte setting but
they had more concerns on their plate
same thing in Eastern Ontario where the
Mohawks at Tyendinaga had shut down a
major CN rail line for nearly three
weeks
protesters support the wood sotin but
they are also demanding progress on
their own failed land claim talks and
those who block roads around the Port of
Vancouver earlier in the week also want
to block oil pipelines like the trans
mountain so far the what so itand
hereditary chiefs have declined to give
any advice to these protesters saying
it's not their place but many of those
mounting protests in their support are
also waiting for their cue our
commitment given to continue to support
until such time as the wet so wet and
hereditary chiefs are satisfied and
request that we we stand down not only
us but across the rest of the country is
something that commitment that we've
given a strong economy meanwhile the
Trudeau government is trying to balance
the right to protest against the right
to earn a living
protest
does not and cannot include the right to
stop Canadians from going about their
business from doing their jobs from
living their lives and yet the Trudeau
government has been hesitant about
taking strong action to end these
protests hoping instead that the weekend
of dialogue in northern BC will be
enough to ease tensions on the
barricades across the country Robin
David akin in Ottawa thanks David now to
the 13 Canadians being detained in
Ethiopia they're part of a group of
volunteers and staff with the Alberta
based charity Canadian humanitarian
they're being investigated for claims
they were practicing medicine without
permission and used expired drugs
Global's Liam Nixon broke the story here
on global national last night and is
tracking the story from our Lethbridge
newsroom Liam
Robin we do know the Canadian government
has been in touch with their Ethiopian
counterparts to discuss the situation
and of course Justin Trudeau just
wrapped up a pretty amicable trip to
that country just last month we know the
13 Canadians 10 volunteers and three
staff are still being held at a police
station in the northern Ethiopian city
of Gondar Gondar is the fourth largest
city in Ethiopia with a population of
around 360,000 two Ethiopian staff
members are also still detained Canadian
humanitarian is pushing back on those
allegations in a statement spokesperson
Justin steed says the care they provide
in Ethiopia is the same care they would
provide here in Canada we are vigorously
defending the actions and decisions of
our team knowing that every decision was
made by highly trained and certified
Canadian medical professionals and that
their mission on this trip was to
provide essential medical care to the
citizens of Ethiopia who need it most
International Affairs analyst Michael BA
circu says while Canada is generally
seen as a positive influence the dangers
are very real any aid worker no matter
where you're from has to go into the
field with a very high knowledge I think
of what to expect with proper training
in case something goes sideways that
sort of thing but I think um
for all Canadian aid workers are well
respected as for whether this type of
incident might deter future missions to
the area the circu says that could
happen the one of the unfortunate things
that happens when these events happen is
that it discourages people it
discourages people Canadians from
volunteering or going into this sector
and I hate I would hate to see that
happening because the needs across the
world Direction going up tomorrow is a
national holiday in Ethiopia so that
means the courts are closed but
discussions between government officials
are likely ongoing all in an effort to
bring these Canadians home Robin Liam
Nixon in Lethbridge Alberta there is a
major development tonight in the race to
become the Democratic presidential
nominee US media is reporting that Pete
Buddha judge has decided to drop out
according to reports the former mayor of
South Bend Indiana will make the
announcement in a speech tonight Buddha
jej was the first openly gay
presidential candidate to launch a major
campaign he won the Iowa caucuses last
month by a narrow margin but suffered a
major loss yesterday in South Carolina
well Joe Biden is likely getting a boost
from that news on top of his South
Carolina primary win heading into Super
Tuesday for weeks the former US vice
president was essentially overshadowed
by Bernie Sanders but last night Biden
received 49% of the vote while the
Vermont senator came in at a distant
second with 20% a lot is at stake with
the Super Tuesday contests where the
candidates have to contend with 15
states and territories they must win a
third of the total delegates to win the
nomination
coming up the growing financial impact
of kovat 19
back to our top story the Cova 19
outbreak has also spread to the stock
markets taking them on a wild ride from
record levels to the worst week they've
seen since the 2008 financial crisis
it's Monday in the Middle East and
already trading is down
let's bring in mark Yamada an investment
advisor to talk about this situation
mark why is the virus having such an
effect on the markets well the one thing
the market really hates is uncertainty
and there's a lot of uncertainty around
covent 19:00 well companies are
scrambling to check their supply chains
market participants don't have that
luxury we have to make educated guesses
with less-than-perfect information and
we're just not getting enough
information now so we can expect more
losses on the market this week well you
you really want to encourage people to
think along those lines but until we
have better certainty and of course
we're never going to have complete
certainty until we have more certainty
we're going to be probing for for new
lows and of course the market always
over does it in both directions both the
upside and the downside but we don't yet
have enough information to determine
where the base is is it fair to compare
this to the 2008 financial crisis not
really very different but equally as
scary the 2008 2009 crisis was really
very closely associated with the banking
structure this is less to do with the
banking structure and more to do with
corporate earnings and uncertainties
surrounding what has really become an
integrated global marketplace we depend
on China for an amazing amount of
certain elements of our goods 80 percent
for example of pharmaceutical inputs
come from this particular area in who
Bay and we just don't know how things
are going to change in terms of
inventories could this have an impact on
the next interest rate announcement oh
there's no question about it I think one
thing you can definitely expect over the
next five days is either a single or
concerted effort by central banks around
the world
to provide credit banks around the world
are going to make sure that everybody
knows that credit is available so that
because of the delays that may be
occurring in the banking system that
there should be no problem but of course
it's it's not an antidote to what's
going on in the world but it is a help
mark thank you for your time
still ahead how tower crane safety holds
up against stormy conditions
[Music]
watching global national when Rock
storms hit the concern turns to the
safety of structures and tower cranes
are top of mind there are common sight
in big cities like Toronto where doesn't
stop the skyline tonight Ross Hall
reports on what it takes to stop them
from spelling disaster
they tower over our cities and meld into
our skylines but when severe weather
strikes
cranes can quickly transform from stoic
Giants to destructive force the wind is
clearly the number one culprit Doug
Perry Vic is a professor of engineering
with the University of Toronto he says
in an urban environment Gus can hit
tower cranes from all directions you can
also get wind events between buildings
and there are various effects this
downdraft effect in the venturi or
tunneling effect where wind gets
accelerated through narrow spaces when a
crane isn't in use and strong winds are
expected these structures are set to
weather veining mode they then move more
freely with less surface area exposed to
the most intense winds but when powerful
gusts strike if the crane isn't set to
weathervane the results can be
disastrous how's the elevation goes up
the winds go up okay a 20 kilometer an
hour wind here could very easily be 35
40 kilometers about six storeys high it
is Claudio Montes a nose job to teach
students how to operate these machines
safely is a judgment call there's
certain things you can do it at 50
kilometres an hour and there's certain
things you can't do it 30 kilometres an
hour and learning to deal with various
types of weather is a key part of the
curriculum at this Ontario school
specializing in training crane operators
students practice on this simulator
before dealing with real-life weather
situations but they also need to be
aware of other factors such as the
pressures of a booming housing market
this go go go get it done get it done
kind of attitude if we could just slow
that down a little bit and give
ourselves enough time to think prior to
actually doing the work I think we've
reduced our accidents that way so the
next time a storm hits is there reason
to worry the onus is on the constructor
to make sure that to that extra margin
of safety is there pair of ik says these
structures are safe but contractors need
to make sure the right crane
in the right place for the right job
after all there are limits to what
Mother Nature can throw at these metal
giants in our skies Ross Hall Global
News up next the precious knowledge lost
in the tragedy of flight 7-5 to
it's been more than seven weeks since
Ukraine Airlines flight 752 was shot
down by an Iranian missile killing all
on board including 57 Canadians a number
of the victims were faculty members at
the University of Alberta scholars and
academics who were working on research
projects as Brianna Carsten Smith
reports the University has vowed to
complete their work so their legacies
live on when most kondañña Sh'ma her
husband pedra Mousavi and their two
young girls Daria and dureena were
killed in the Iran plane disaster the
world learned of their tremendous
accomplishments but in this research lab
at the University of Alberta where a
memorial has taken over that success has
long been known I wanted to stay in
academia to keep Morgan's name alive and
her legacy to continue that legacy
includes major advances in the
engineering community work that was far
from done the professor had been having
a project with Enbridge developing
flexible sensors to wrap around
pipelines and detect corrosion drones
flying above could monitor the condition
instead of having to dig down the vision
was to have kind of a leak free by
blinds but completing that work is a
challenge gone with dr. Donna Sherrod is
decades of knowledge we are hopeful that
all of those projects that would end up
almost the same or even better than what
Morgan was expected that includes the
development of a non-invasive blood test
for diabetes patients our high end
research that could enable us to
identify a significantly small and close
to the limit of detection in glucose
level sounds saying in another U of a
building professors are running into a
similar problem nassim Romano Farr was
also killed January 8th the promising
master's student had been working on a
SmartWatch app to help wheelchair users
protect their shoulders they can if
needed modify the the propulsion pattern
now because of grant funding deadlines
her team is forced to move on without
her I always try to
and dealing with that with thinking
about people around the world who would
benefit from outcome of her research
it's my countless projects that the
University will move forward dedication
from those left behind
to honor those who were lost mojgan is
with us her smiles her words wisdom her
Egypt to innovate and serve the
community is living with us and will
live with us as long as we live
Briana Kirsten Smith global news and
that is global national for this Sunday
I'm Robin Gill tonight your Canada is
greens Pond Newfoundland and Labrador
thank you for watching and Donna fries
and we'll be back here tomorrow have a
great night
[Music]
you